de vuelta a los estrados internacionales
este miércoles colom y nicaragua se
enfrentan de nuevo por tercera vez en
dos décadas estas dos naciones van a la
corte internacional de justicia para
esclarecer los límites marítimos se
trata del fallo de la corte de la haya
de 2012 que él otorgó a nicaragua
370 kilómetros del mar caribe desde su
costa restándole más de 70 mil
kilómetros cuadrados al mar colombiano y
por eso estamos acudiendo a esta
instancia pero siempre bajo la premisa
clara de cumplir con el artículo 101 de
nuestra constitución a partir del cual
los límites de nuestro país solamente
pueden ser modificados a través de
tratados de límites ratificado por el
congreso de la república el fallo de la
haya confirmó la soberanía de colombia
de los 7 cayos cercanos a las islas de
san andrés providencia y santa catalina
sin embargo estos nuevos límites
marítimos y la jurisdicción de agua
sobre el archipiélago provocaron el
rechazo del gobierno del ex presidente
colombiano juan manuel santos lo que
está en juego
si colombia le ha violado unos derechos
especialmente económicos a nicaragua y
si de otro lado es nicaragua la que ha
desconocido los derechos del pueblo
raizal a pescar en sus bancos
tradicionales de pesca y si es nicaragua
la que se ha apropiado
unilateralmente y de forma ilegal de
grandes porciones del mar caribe por su
parte del gobierno de nicaragua
compareció este lunes ante la haya y
pidió que colombia cumpla con el fallo
además presentó pruebas de un incidente
internacional en 2015 entre guardacostas
de ambos países en el que colombia les
advertía que no se adentrarán más en el
mar el gobierno colombiano presentará
dos contrademandas tras el reclamo de
soberanía de nicaragua